这是我们AI生成的好莱坞电影大片风格预告
以前动辄上帝的影片,现在一个人加AI就能搞定
我是如何做的,先看成片
an unregulated digital consciousness uploaded to the public network, I can't bear the consequences
then why did you help built it?
Listen, the omega life breach still haunts me, that was a disaster son, you know what the rich do with your technology
Listen, I'm just a scientist, I don't do politics, all I know is this will tore society apart
You better check this shit out, courts don't need testimony anymore
Take the scrap if you want it, just scrub the serial numbers, and just so you know, no one's ever put a mind in a machine before
Think about the next generation, it's already falling apart out there doctor, I'm not doing this for you, I'm doing it for them
I'll ask you one last time, are you sure about this?
Hands up! You are arrested!
Hey!
Disfurse!
这是我制作师的画部,一共分为五个步骤
第一步我花了比后期制作还长的时间来做人物关系的设计
主角的动机和行为逻辑包括它出现的场景其实都有剧情线
我是先写完完整的剧本才去做的预告
而不是杂乱做了一些碎片
第二步图片制作
在图片生成的流程中我用了大量的抽卡和控制人物关系
一个小的制作技巧就是
我会给画面生成第一张基调图
它的作用是用来定位全篇的画面调形
我们可以从剧情中较为适合的部分摘一个镜头作为生成标准
我这里用的是主角被机械警察逮捕的画面作为基调图
因为它可以体现机器人同时又可以体现我们的男主
我们可以看到我在大量的图片生成中
反复修改题字词最终选择了最合适的画面作为基调图
大家可以看到它并不是一次性就能生成非常标准
非常舒服的图片
反而有很多图片它的质量是非常糟糕的
所以这个需要大家花时间去调整自己的题字词
反复去试
然后就是根据剩下的剧情去出掉相应的场景图片
第三
在图身视频的阶段我们仍然有很多镜头需要浪费掉
不过没关系一些剧情为主
导演最重要的能力就是做取舍
第四步
我会根据影片的基调去生AI预告片的音乐
当然我们的音乐肯定它是不能直接用的
但是绝大部分的这个音乐片段
AI已经是做的非常不错的
需要我们后期二次对音乐进行合成
第五步
再把这些所有的素材内容剪辑到一起
这样一个好莱坞风格的电影预告就已经做完了
由于基础工作我们已经做的差不多了
所以这个片子想要做成片
随时可以进入到正片的制作流程
同样这样的影片也可以测试一下
什么样类型的片子
对于市场这个流量反馈是OK的
我们要决定是不是要做
我是罐头
希望这期分享对大家了解AI影视更有帮助
感谢您的关注
我们下期再见